Okay,
yes,
yeah,
yeah.
Natasha,
put your phone because
you're trying,
but the struggle was real.
I wasn't sure it's not coming up.
There it goes.
This interface.
It's very hard.
Um,
are you guys worried that by calling
your tour endless honeymoon,
you might put the jinx on it?
Sorta like how rob and black China and
doing a reality show.
A jinx on what our marriage or the tour.
We can pivot.
We can pivot into the endless divorce
tour very quickly,
right?
Because you guys will be friends.
Even if you miss,
you hit the rocks strictly homeys tour.
Well,
the way we thought of it as we're in
Newport,
Rhode Island,
we learned about this rich couple who
went on a 10 year honeymoon and then
they came back with four kids and I just
thought that sounded so romantic to be
so rich that you dislike.
Went away for a decade.
Yeah.
You have kids on the fly.
You Go away,
newlyweds,
you come back.
Grandparents.
That's super bowl too.
Like they don't even know their doctor.
They're in fucking Sweden.
There are rich people.
Those people were so richmond.
Do you know about the newport that the
seat of wealth?
That was newport,
Rhode Island.
Oh yeah.
I used to do a lot of gigs in Rhode
Island.
There's Caesar's insane mansions.
They're the in the,
well in the gilded age,
1900.
Basically 90 percent of the wealth in
America was in Rhode Island and then
everyone else was living in squalor.
They hadn't established personal income
tax yet.
It was like the years right before
personal income tax had been established
in this country.
So people had like 35 indoor servants,
55 outdoor servants like you could.
People would come from Australia and
boats and you would just make them your.
It was like slavery,
but
the show,
the endless listen to mature.
We do an extended lecture on personal
income tax and the history and slavery.
Yeah,
no.
Nice.
So another period is based on that.
That's how we know about it,
but yeah,
they were like these people.
It was the carnegies and the
rockefellers and these like seat of
power,
like Illuminati old.
You had a billion dollars a hundred
years ago.
Like these people or they were just.
But now we've come full circle and
people have figured out how to legally
steal money and not paying income tax.
So but not that many.
I mean the other thing,
but don't like the Romney's of the
world.
Don't they know how to not pay or are
you talking about?
Well like the like politicians don't.
They kind of know how to.
You're talking about.
She's talking about big old corporate
oligarchy billionaire people figured out
any super rich people are going to try
really hard to hold onto their money and
pay as little taxes as possible and form
llcs and corporations that don't kind of
jazz.
But it is funny.
The comedians are like mostly super
liberal and they were all like,
man,
we got Bernie and we gotta like pay
these high tax rates and anyway I'm
incorporated on my llc name is.
Sounds like you're doing a corporate
fiction too.
Differ
for entertainers,
but here's the problem.
Like where's the going?
Like I'd
be willing to give away more money and
tax dollars if I knew that it was a rock
solid establishment.
They really knew what to do.
And if you could pick,
if you could tick like little feel,
a little bubbles,
like,
oh,
I like most of my money to go to
education.
No,
nothing to.
Nothing to that.
That'd be amazing.
Would be.
But the country be fucked.
Yeah.
The roads to fall apart quicker.
Everything would fall apart.
You know,
cops would be out of business.
Well no,
because half of the country at least
would be like all my money.
The cops,
all my mother did defense.
I would love to see.
I would love to.
I don't,
I wouldn't love to do it because I just
don't think that that amount of power
should be in people's hands without a
lot of research first.
You know,
I think that's big part of the problem.
Even running for president and voting
for president,
you don't have to have any research done
before you choose a candidate.
You just like them.
And also you don't have to have done any
research to be the president.
I guess I'm a hillary person.
Yeah.
You can become a hillary person just
because you didn't want to reality show
contestant or whatever the fuck you was.
What?
That's the crazy thing about,
and I.
I do think,
I think we're talking about this last
time.
I do think trump,
if he's doing anything good for American
society,
he's pointing out how ridiculous and
arbitrary the worship of the American
president is.
Oh yeah.
That's not presidential.
Presidential means that you look
dignified while you bomb a village in
Yemen,
like we should just destroy
presidential.
As an idea of adult said that he called
it the uniquely American religion of
President Worship President worship.
Yeah.
That is really.
I mean it's really just a new version of
King's.
Oh,
that's so funny that our whole
foundation mythology is based on the
rejection of the king and we immediately
established king kingship,
which is what they did in.
In Christianity.
I think of Christianity this way,
like it's based in this Judaic religion
that says,
let's get rid of the idea of a man that
you worship or a figure or a God that
you bow in front of them.
There's one right in front of us,
right?
Let's get rid of a statue that you bow
down in front of and the next religion
was like,
oh,
let's watch a human being like,
it's so weird that it's so in us.
Well,
it's Alpha male chimpanzee stuff.
We always try to look to the number one
though,
the one that knows the most,
the oldest with the most scars.
It's gone to the battle as the most
wisdom lead us because you want to know
which snakes are poisonous and what
plants you can eat and what's going to
kill you.
Right.
And and,
and everybody worships the past.
That's what's so funny to me about an
American.
It's the day after July fourth and
everybody talks about the founding
fathers is like,
those were dudes who had the education
of it.
There were brilliant people in the 18
hundreds and 17 hundreds,
but I'm not like trying to.
I'm not trying to go to a doctor from
the founding fathers days.
Yeah.
People price dunk people probably did
probably stank.
It probably just would let people
smelled like back then,
like if you call it a gal after a bath,
you were psyched.
Bath is that.
Let's be honest about what a bath is.
It's asshole and vagina soup.
You're sitting in a big teapot,
but you don't buy your balls in there.
It's just the vessels in women put their
vaginas in.
Men they have.
They hold up their assholes,
their dicks and balls,
so they don't concern me what a guy
smells like,
but what a girl smells like,
concerns me,
but maybe it wouldn't have back then.
Maybe it wouldn't have.
Yeah.
Maybe just your standards change.
I mean,
if you're horny enough,
you don't care.
That is true.
I'll never forget this passage
always,
but you're an incredibly horny person
because
my wife.
Let me just say,
guys,
my wife is so horny.
I love that word.
How you did it in a sort of a gay.
Why don't listen to funny that like
being more mobile is gay is gay.
If you just start going like this,
people go as gay as fuck.
There's A.
There's a story about Tom Cruise.
We heard this,
that he came to,
I can't remember who it was,
some comedy person who's like a normal
human being,
right?
Like,
but famous but not like Tom Cruise
fairness.
Right.
Tom Cruise,
like connected with that person.
I can't make it a better story if I
remember who it was.
But if somebody like that,
like your level or or,
or,
or like a mark duplass or.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I don't know who mark says,
well he's the guy at your level.
No,
no,
no.
Is the duplass Jamie knows who everybody
is.
I don't know who the duplass brothers
there.
They made the show togetherness on Hbo.
My point isn't about the duplass
brothers is like,
they were just like semi famous.
Not like
Tom Cruise cruise got so horny she wants
to get to the fire.
So see he got invited to a superbowl
party at this person's house.
Right?
Like imagine if Tom Cruise is coming to
your house for the superbowl superbowl
party.
He was like,
oh whoa.
Asking Tom Cruise?
And he says,
yes honey.
You said yes.
What do we do?
Right.
And it might've been Tom cruise be like,
I think I will be among the humans
today.
So Tom,
because it barely shows up with a brand
new,
like clearly fresh football that his
assistant like,
you know,
he's like tossing like a literal brand
new football in the air.
Right.
And they're all talking about marriage
at some point in the day and goes,
do you know what the best part of being
married is though?
Right?
Fucking your wife,
am I right?
You just fuck your wife.
And everybody's like,
felt like tumbleweeds are all three of
like a robot,
like an alien visiting us.
He must be amazing to hang out with.
I would love to hang out with him.
Fucking your wife.
Right?
I mean when you're that famous,
your work ethic,
it's like you just devote everything to
that I think because like I have my,
my agents were like,
they know that the agents who are Tom
Cruise agents,
they said Tom Cruise always gets back
within an hour when we send a script
because I'll like keep a script for like
three weeks.
And then by the time I read it,
the parts we can cast
Tom Cruise,
we'll read a script and an hour and get
back to them and either like it or not
it like he's
just like on the ball,
he's,
he's like,
he's trying to win,
he's won.
It's an inhuman instinct because our
human instinct is to just atrophy in a
way.
I mean you have to kind of fight it,
but easy to be lazy and to
procrastinate.
It's definitely easy to be lazy,
but it's not if you're going to be Tom
cruise or really have to be on the ball,
there's no other way.
It doesn't just,
he doesn't know time job.
That's not just what's going on.
And those,
there's some weird alien sort of
behavior patterns that we don't
recognize as being normal.
Like when he jumped up on Oprah's couch
is like,
I'm in love,
I'm in love him and love.
And everyone's like,
what the fuck is going on here?
Right Person?
No,
it's like a person who doesn't
understand French,
but you're speaking French to a French
person who's saying all the right words,
like,
what the fuck is wrong with this guy?
It seems like every choice he makes
outside of acting is based on what he's
assuming normal human beings think is
the normal behavior because the love is
when you jump on a couch and go,
I love her.
Which is informed by movies really.
Right.
Like that's more movie like,
right.
That's like John Cusak and say anything
like,
oh,
that's what love looks like.
It's not,
you know,
or telling a bunch of the fellows,
oh,
we're gonna have sex.
Talk with the fellows.
Also,
I looked at my wife off the friction of
her vagina.
Makes me just sploosh alright guys.
And everyone's like,
we're sick of fucking r was never.
I've,
I've just done relate to that joke that
you made.
That's so sweet.
Yeah.
What a fucking strange guy.
He might be one of the strangest guys of
all time.
I wish you would just come clean with
like one day just to sit down and just
be like,
given some ecstasy and have them just
talk about who he is.
Like I don't even know the fuck I am and
now I've been scientology for so long.
Like 13 guys last year was worried.
They're going to tell.
I'm always worried.
They're going to tell you.
He did Chris Hardwick's podcast,
right?
He did.
He did a one on one interview.
I listened to it recently.
I wish you could get them on here
because you,
you,
you get a,
you get in.
But I don't think you could pierce that
impenetrable layer.
I think he be fake with you to.
Even if he's fake,
you find out if he's fake to find some
stuff.
I will visit.
You still appears.
He was telling Chris like,
I love movies.
You know,
I'm passionate about movies.
And Chris Goes,
oh yeah,
like what are some of your favorite
movies?
This is how politically like constructed
he is.
He goes,
yeah,
just move a movies.
All movies,
all movies.
So he quit.
He was
just no different.
Biggest movie star couldn't pick three
movies that have inspired because he
didn't want them to like,
you know,
a Spielberg,
a Bruckheimer and the blah blah blah,
because then he piss off Coppola and
Scorsese and you know,
I mean,
it's all a construct.
God,
I want to meet him.
Yeah.
I can't believe he did Chris's.
That's so cool.
You should have them on the show.
You could get it.
I think I got.
I got faith.
You could get it.
I've had this guy on Ron miscavige who's
David Miscavige is dad.
Oh Wow.
Who's
scientology?
And I had Leah Remini on and we talked
for three hours about how crazy her life
and scientology was near a classic sp.
There's no way you're getting a
suppressive person.
Oh No,
I'm not.
I'm just misunderstood.
I got to say though,
that the more I learned about the
Catholic faith and all these kid fuckers
keep coming out,
the more I'm like,
that's the worst one.
Did you see the new one keepers don't
know the new.
There's a thousand cases of child
molesting that they just uncovered.
Shut down that religion.
Catholic trump monsters.
No,
no,
I'm not doing a pit,
but all $8,000 it was connected to the
church at Jamie will find it.
It was just some.
I mean I didn't even read it because I
looked at the headline and the first
thought was de and second thought was,
Ugh,
like you just can't.
I mean it's so much worse than like
making some unbelieved they can get
acting work like whatever scientology
does.
Like the Catholic religion is like their
fucking little girls and boys and like
permanently ruining their lives,
making them have like terrible
flashbacks,
making them have like wide chunks of
memory that they just don't remember.
Then they do remember and it's like,
it's just the worst thing you can do.
And how do you like sexual problems?
I'm not Catholic and Jewish now.
Well,
you know the pope,
the pope,
ratzinger,
that guy.
One of the things that they do,
one of the reasons why he stepped down
was because they,
they found out that he was one of the
guys that used to move people around
common.
He was one of the guys.
When someone get caught molesting
children,
he would move into a new new precinct
that,
what do you call it?
That's what takes your breath away.
We live actually right next to a
rehabilitation center,
former rehabilitation center for wayward
priests on our street
and I was like,
oh.
I always thought,
oh,
wayward praise.
Like I wonder what that means.
And then after we saw that movie
spotlight,
we looked it up and that's exactly where
they were.
Housing p one was one of the places they
were housing the molesters
follow.
It makes this really interesting point
about the church,
which is the commonly held sort of folk
belief about the Catholic church is that
when you take away someone's ability to
have sex,
you will.
You will concentrate their sex drive and
pervert it and you'll become a child
molester.
And what?
Spotlight the movie sort of point that
it makes us.
It's the other way around.
It's that that basically what you're a
child molester,
you go to the church because you know
they'll,
they'll give you a haven.
Don't feel cover for you.
It's true though,
like it is hard to become a priest.
You have to like study scripture for.
I mean,
how long has he been here?
Did molest a child?
You got to groom them,
you got to hang out.
You know what I mean?
But seriously know how true that.
So ratzinger moved to God that went onto
molest 100 deaf kids.
Yeah.
I saw this documentary because they
couldn't talk about it.
There would be.
Yeah,
but no one's gonna listen to them.
It's not like they can just start
talking,
you know what I mean?
It's like it's a weight just.
I mean he was working with deaf kids,
deaf orphans.
Well,
it's just,
it's not.
Nobody would listen to a deaf person.
It's it.
This is how scams one step removed.
Exactly.
It's one more.
What you want when you want as a
Predator is,
is the most vulnerable person that you
can be predatory towards.
It's like a documentary keepers.
It wasn't until this girl came to the
priest and said,
I actually have been molested.
He was like,
Oh,
you have have you?
And then he started molesting or waited
for her to come into.
It was a confession.
Found that she was weak,
she was weak.
And then that's who we picked.
So it's like,
why remember these Nigeria?
Speaking of psychotic.
It's insane.
Yeah.
But that's what they want.
They,
the molester.
Lester loves the weak,
the weak and vulnerable.
Because if they go to a strong confident
child who they know,
what would it be like if you touch me,
I'll tell my fucking dad molested.
That girl's got a big mouth also.
You do not touch her.
I've seen your,
your baby pictures.
You want a hug.
Okay.
And I was always trying to.
Yeah.
But it's very much always boys,
right?
Keepers.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It's girls and boys.
It's like who?
I've only seen documentaries on boys,
but the boys thing is weird,
but I kind of.
I do believe there's a math to like
suppressing someone's sexuality and then
it's just gonna come out in these other
ways.
Well,
I think that also monsters are
orientation is spread equally across
monsters.
So oriented.
Yeah.
I think that.
I don't even know.
Are you gay?
If you're a child molester,
likes little boys,
is that even gay?
That seems like a third thing.
Just you're,
you're,
you're not even in a sexual zone
anymore.
Now you're in a pathology zone.
But since the cases are so,
there's so many cases,
like maybe we should just let priests
get married or something needs to
change.
Well,
they used to be able to,
but they were rockstars.
The problem was back in the days like
the,
during the Lutheran days when Martin
Luther was around,
priests controlled everything.
I mean,
they fucked everybody's wives.
They,
they,
the pope.
The pope had wives and children.
Pope's had wives,
they had children,
they had money,
they had armies.
The Roman Catholic Pope controlled
armies.
They controlled troops.
Like it was a totally different scene
and then somewhere along the line they
were fucking so many women that were
like,
Hey,
here's the new role.
You're going to be a priest.
You can't fucking chicks.
And then just the whole thing went,
hey,
does anybody know why that happened?
Why the changeover happened?
Because they were rock stars.
Because there were banging everybody.
No Sir.
Why they made them not raw.
Okay.
It,
they were too irresponsible.
This is what I've read.
What I've read is that there were,
there was a real concern amongst people
that were,
you know,
under the tutelage of these priests that
these guys were out of control.
They're just banging everybody
find out what was the reason why they
made them not able to say,
I wonder what you think that is.
It wasn't that long ago.
Elaine was like a thousand years ago.
It might've been less.
That's so interesting.
I think it was less than a thousand
years ago because I know that during the
[inaudible] con era,
the pope still at armies and I think
still,
I think there were still allowed be
married and have children
and they were using their religious
status to abuse
their power and probably probably women
would like fall for them too.
There was no cigarette.
If there's no musicians,
there's no comedian who was going to go
to the are going to go.
The gestures are.
They had comics back then.
It was good with like a floppy hat.
Yeah,
but they were like cruise ship comics.
They couldn't get out of line at all.
They got killed.
I still rock stars.
They were just like had white hair and
like,
what's the deal with the latrine that
you have to shift in?
What is the deal with cornish game hen
the white hair play the piano.
That was later.
That was like,
yeah,
this is like a dude plucking a lute.
Right?
I'd like to find out.
Yeah,
probably right.
Your harp have a timeline.
Is this idea that the guy,
the itinerant singer that would come to
talent and luck pluck the loot and tell
like the tail was always fucking
everybody everywhere went.
That's got to be who we,
who.
We all came from.
It was like Robert Plant came from the
gestures.
Rock are versus comedian,
right?
We were the people who would come in on
a wagon and juggling balls of manure.
You know,
like the king has the years of that.
I would like to see you on the head with
a baguette.
Do you think that you guys have like
genetic ancestry to former comedians?
Um,
I believe in that more than most of us.
I believe.
I don't believe,
I just feel like I have a blood memory
of like,
like for example,
I do think there are people in comedy
who are doing it because that's where
like the energy is right now and they're
just like trying to like make money and.
Right.
Yeah.
Or whoever or.
I think it's moved beyond that.
It's like now it's like everybody that
you would have been a dj when I was like
17 is now a comedian.
Right?
Is a lot of that.
But I love you guys.
Well,
what I was going to.
I don't really care.
I mean I think you just have to like
yourself.
It doesn't bother me.
I think it's cool because when you go
big then the 10 percent of geniuses that
wouldn't have started.
If it wasn't cool.
We'll start and then the 90 percent of
people that we're going to be garbage.
What do they.
They don't matter.
Damn Ninety 10,
Huh?
Fuck.
Probably less.
Probably 90 nine.
One genius person that starts comedy.
That to becoming like a forget genius
person that starts comedy does a set at
an open mic to becomes like one of the
great comedians,
like even in the top 10 percent of
comedians that's,
that's gotta be one percent.
That's the point that time.
But the problem with is like you say
once they start,
because the 99 point nine percent that
start never even make it.
That's part of it.
Yeah.
But like it's like the one percent that
do the point one percent that actually
become professional committees.
Like how many people out of your group
of open microbes that used to hang with,
how many are still doing standup?
That ratio because how many of them have
a TV show?
All of them.
Like it's easier to be famous now.
So your ratios are a little off.
I remember when.
Well yeah,
no,
the,
the numbers are very start.
I remember when I first started like I
would have,
I would have fucked a let a man fuck me
50 times to get like a Montreal spot and
now it's like 50 times.
I've thought about it a lot and they
would,
they would rub my back very gently and
smuggling take me on like Alonzo Bowden.
Okay.
That he could do 25 times.
Dude.
I looked at Alonzo Bowden's fingers once
and I was like,
there are men with Dick smaller than
your finger off for sure.
Bottom line.
Dick.
Smaller than your finger.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
well that's rough.
If that's true.
It's true.
Anyway,
Alonzo,
if you're listening,
every time I look at your hands,
I think it was Dick's small ticks.
Interesting.
But my boy,
Oh,
I would've done anything for a Montreal
spot or,
or,
or a spot on,
on,
on the tonight show.
And now there's young comics who like
are like,
Nah,
I'm not really trying to like be a
second lead on a show right now.
I'm really waiting.
Well from my vehicle it things have
changed.
I dated a girl that was like that.
She was like,
I don't want to do TV.
I'm holding out for film because I was
on a television show at the time and she
was saying that she didn't want to do
TV.
It's like it was beneath her.
Oh,
and you're doing tv at the time.
Was that news radio?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Great.
So I'm a fan of that show.
I took an acting class with Paris Hilton
and she and the teacher was like,
who wants to do tv?
And everyone raised their hand except
her.
And it was like,
who wants to do just movies in Paris?
Hilton,
right.
It's terrific course once we legit.
That's so fun.
That was the thing in the nineties.
Yeah.
I guess know the Paris Hilton is one of
the top highest paid djs in the world.
She can't have good taste in music.
Be a DJ.
She's not a DJ.
Also has like 20 perfumes and suck
should go into deejaying.
It seems like it's an open market.
Dominate if you have half a sense of
entertainment.
That guy's got a billboard on sunset.
Most is like,
he is like deejaying at a swimming pool
in Las Vegas.
It was a huge famous celebrity Dj.
You know how in La you'll always know
what's happening in Vegas.
Paul Harris or one of those guys,
and it was literally you look down and
it's like Vegas Swim Club,
Dj in a pool,
but those pools will have 15,000 people
stuffed into the area going crazy.
Horny dude.
That's probably where I would hang out
with one girl.
She's going to go hang out.
She's on her way.
She's going,
we're stopping there on the honeymoon
tour where a Nixon mask and just go
crazy and mix it with like a beautiful
naked woman body with a Nixon mask on.
I heard that they recently,
this could be bullshit,
started making more money on their
nightclubs and on the.
On the casinos.
That's got to be true.
It may be.
I don't know.
I don't know what the numbers are,
but I would imagine they make a lot of
money on the casinos.
People like,
what's up?
I just heard John Taffer,
that guy that does bar rescue talking
about it on another interview,
he said they'll go in on Friday night
and make about 500,000 bucks for their
clubs show and then wake up the next
morning and do the pool at noon for 150.
You don't know.
You're talking about the actual
performance.
We're talking about the club itself.
You're talking about the casino.
The casino makes.
But imagine that if the Dj mix $650,000
for a weekend,
you got to multiply that by what?
Twenty 100 percent.
Well,
they may have the odd person like I am
on that show dice about Andrew dice
clay.
Have you ever had him do this?
Many times as you know?
I mean I didn't know a real thing,
but in the show,
the whole premise is that he's paying
off his gambling debt to the casino
because it's like $800,000 and it's the
only way you can pay it back.
But that's a true story.
He was in debt,
like he would lose $800,000 in one
night.
So as long as they have people like
that,
they must be making a lot of money,
right?
Yeah.
There's always gonna be.
It was always like the old lady like
putting in nickels but then there's also
like dice,
but you also have to think like how much
money does it cost to run a casino?
The overhead is insane.
Right.
It's also,
they also exist in this odd like venn
diagram of like a legal business and an
old world like criminal.
And I don't mean that in a Mafia.
Like don't they have like India,
like why is it even legal for them?
Yeah.
For them to let someone rack up an
$800,000 debt,
like a normal business business would
say,
sir,
you're $20 over your limit.
So we're going to go.
They just know,
like he's got credit,
he's nice,
he's going to make money.
He's gonna.
He gambled away the deed to his house at
the Riviera and like they just lost my
hip,
hurt my Nana's wedding ring.
And then someone told me when I was at,
I was at foxwoods and they said because
I was performing and they said that at
Mohegan Sun,
they're like,
yeah,
it's gotten really bad at Mohegan Sun
when you gamble away your car,
they won't even give you a ride home.
But we at foxwoods or giving people
rides like it's happening.
Like people are just like,
they run out of money and they're like,
okay,
I could win it all back if I just sell
the car.
And it's like they don't.
Yeah.
Here's what's interesting though,
if you,
when they ban you,
like my friend Dana,
Dana white is a notorious gambler,
but he wins millions of dollars
sometimes.
He's,
I think he said he lost his much as
$1,000,000 and he's won as much as 7
million in another.
Holy Shit.
Has He gotten banned from playing?
Really?
Yes.
Dana.
He's a celebrity.
He only does he get banned,
but he gets banned and then he pulls the
UFC out of them.
Like these two do ufc at the palms and
he killed the palms and the palms
bandom.
So he's like,
fuck you Ben,
you and I moved to the hard rock or
wherever the hell they moved in next.
But yeah,
they,
they've banned him from a bunch of
casinos because he's really good at
blackjack.
Wow.
Can you.
What stakes is what?
What's the minimum bet for the Dana
White blocks?
I wish I knew.
That sounds fucking crazy.
How is that legal?
The band someone once they win at the
thing you're saying?
I'm saying
these casinos are not fully legal there.
Like in this weird area.
They reserve the right to ban new if you
kicked their ass,
which is crazy.
Can they say you're card counting or
something?
Not Card County.
I mean even if you are,
it doesn't matter.
It's legal.
I mean you can do whatever the fuck you
want I think.
I think it's as long as it's
on your head,
if you're not using a calculator or
something that's technically within the
rules of the game because your job is to
sit down and I guess cow card counting.
But blackjack.
I mean you're supposed to not know.
Like if you say,
if you have knowledge,
so we'll still ignore it and you know
how to count cards.
That's so stupid.
It's like a girl going to a bar watching
a guy roofie or drink up.
Can't pay attention to that.
Set the rules to know what the fucking
rules are.
Right?
The rules are like if you know how many
decks they're using and you know what
you know when not to hit and just play
it smart and count and thinking
calculate.
I know I also been a wiser retread.
Why does Dana the root thing,
we all accepted it sort of.
It's your house.
We were like,
ah,
Joe,
you got that?
But I was like,
hm,
that's
uh,
why?
Why does Dana white gamble or have no
idea?
The famous basketball player that like
Charles Barkley,
what drives those people?
There were so rich.
Why rules?
What is also people that have been hit
in the head a lot?
Dana has been hitting the head a lot.
I'm notoriously impulsive and
notoriously susceptible to addiction.
Whether it's gambling,
addiction,
alcoholic.
Yeah.
It's a big part of cte,
chronic traumatic encephalopathy,
which you see.
I think I said it right.
That's a brain damage from getting hit
in the head.
A big part of it,
it was a lot of boxing when he was
young,
has been,
has dome,
rattled a gigabit time.
Scott,
that dome rattled here.
You're not supposed to get punched in
the head ever.
Right.
You definitely get punched in the head
multiple times a day for years.
What about like you train right now I
don't do any kickboxing sparring,
you know,
because of that.
Yeah,
and even in Jujitsu,
you like slam into someone's knee
accidentally or ahead.
You get your head bonked your dome
rabbit.
It's not that common,
but when I was kickboxing boy I got hit
in the head a lot to the point where I
just like.
Sometimes I think about some of the
decisions I've made.
I'm like,
what's going on in their life?
What screws are loose?
Even with headgear,
you're saying you're still worse.
Here's worse.
Pickier.
It actually makes an a,
an artificial lever like save your head.
Is this large?
It means if you clip it here,
it's gotten more of a fulcrum effect,
whereas if your head is smaller and
compact and you just take it here,
so Richard Nixon mask would be bad
because they had a big old chin
knocking,
knocking little bit the rubber in the
mask,
but the the idea is not necessarily just
the initial impact,
it's how much your head moves,
like how might look.
The stronger your neck is,
the less likely you already get brain
damage.
So these guys do a lot of neck exercises
just just just to keep their head stable
when it gets hit.
The idea is like the more your head
moves,
the more your brain's going swish around
inside your dome and and break off the
connective tissue.
That's also part of the problem is
This like really soft,
almost like cotton candy,
like tissue that connects your brain to
the skull.
Which stuff gets ripped up.
Would you rather be a nfl?
Whatever the guy that linebacker thought
it is a chore or a Longterm Prize
Fighter,
longterm prize fighter for sure.
Longterm prize fighters can get through
it.
Like there's guys like Bernard Hopkins
that fought into his fifties who speaks
well,
you know,
and there's a.
see the problem is even guys that speak
well,
there's the weird shit that they do,
the impulsive stuff.
There's like if you talk to people that
are cte experts,
they tell you some really disturbing
things about brain damage,
about how it manifests itself in the
weird things that men find themselves
doing.
They don't even know why they're doing
it.
They're just doing it and like real
impulsive behavior and just stomping on
the gas on the highway and just like
weird gambling stuff and sex stuff and
drug stuff.
And a lot of it is connected to cte.
What have you looked over at?
Hofstra was crying,
looking at me.
So watching MMA,
like where they're like doing 69 and
just arriving,
arriving.
You're like,
one's got the head and in his dick and
then the other one's got his stick and
they just kinda like ride back and
forth.
And then just like one of the main
commentator
say,
right,
he's got,
oh,
he's got his head in his dick and
they're rising photons that have said
things along those lines.
See,
I listened
sport.
You have to understand from a woman
who's not into sports and then sees that
it's,
it's like I don't understand it.
She comes in and she says,
always did derisively did your team win?
I'm like,
there are no teams.
I mean I'm just
there barefoot.
Like they maybe have been fucking game.
That's the video.
The video game lets you get a little gay
or than the actual shoot.
Actually,
that's a good one.
You can actually fuck it was a great
game.
Could be no,
it looks like a dude that's a.
that's a dude a triangle.
So it's people who don't.
They don't care about brain damage
though.
Like this sport,
this sport brings.
What is that funny?
I don't you think that's important.
They don't care about the cartilage that
connects their head
cartilages are the connective tissue,
connective tissue.
It's not that.
It's not that they don't care,
it's just that this is something that
they started doing when they were young.
They got really good at it and they see
it as a path to make career and they
like thrills.
They like doing things dangerous and
excitements and exciting.
Some of them just accept the risks and
some of them say,
I would rather live a dangerous life.
That's exciting than a really fucking
boring.
Like sitting on the couch atrophying.
I can respect that.
I mean,
I.
of course
that's funny though.
This is like,
was like going to like on Davinci's
podcasts and being like,
I don't know about this art stuff.
I don't know about business
can take it.
I think you're right.
No,
you're right.
My perspective is when I see it,
but I now.
Now you put it like that too.
It's like what?
What's the alternative?
Get A,
get a job in a factory or get a job,
you die.
This is temporary.
This
is not going to last.
Right?
So for them it's like,
how am I going to use my meat vehicle?
Yeah.
And am I going to use it for fun?
Just go crazy.
And I mean that's a,
that's the thought process behind it is
like,
yeah,
I know I'm doing damage to it.
And I,
you know,
I know a lot of guys that have known
when they were in their prime where they
were just killing everybody and now they
are broken.
That's it.
I know guys who can't even brush their
teeth,
their shoulders are so shot.
They have to like brush their teeth
lefthanded and they suck at it and the
crazy fucking move their head.
And how old are they in their thirties?
Yeah.
There is something about the human
animal that wants.
It's an interesting facet of humanity
that wants to achieve greatness for some
reason.
I will see the glory of winning in that
too is also directly related to the
danger of doing it.
It's like there's something dangerous
about it that makes it super exciting.
If you pull it off,
it's winning.
A fight is,
it's a crazy feeling
more than making all these other people
happy too because people have voted on,
you know,
or how do you do it?
You vote on them or whatever.
Like you bet on them.
I mean it's like you're,
it's so many people just.
I've noticed so many people get their
mood is changed if their team wins.
So it's like
the problem with mma though I read when
Chuck Liddell started losing is when I
realized like MMA is not a good sport
for like having to have your guy when
eventually your guy will always lose
always because they'll get older.
That's just the inevitable reality.
Exactly.
The team dynamics,
your team can always be a winner,
but if you root for one fight or that
federal get old and the young people
will come in and it's like 38.
That's way old.
Thirty eight is whale,
so like 32 or something.
Especially now with drug testing,
it used to be back in the day that when
you would get tested,
it was really like they would say it's
like an intelligence test.
It's more than a drug test,
like just don't take anything the
remaining few days before your test and
they just testing your pee for like
really obvious stuff,
but now it's super comprehensive and
they use Usada,
US anti-doping association and they,
they fucking crawl up your ass with a
microscope.
People wake you up checking for what
people want.
Yes.
They are in the room.
Will look at your Dick because guys are
used rubber dam.
Yeah.
I went to Rehab when I was a kid so I
know I knew all the tricks to wizard
eaters or you'd get your homie to piss
into a bag and you'd have the bag in
your pocket.
What kind of drugs are mma?
People doing?
Steroids.
Oh right.
It's not like I know nothing about it.
Like,
well that to make sense.
Legal.
So they're all doing it.
Why would they do it if it's illegal?
Joe?
I got to say your impression of Natasha.
Okay.
No roles.
Did you illegal drugs or.
No,
now I'm horny.
Okay,
hold on.
I just thought that people had a,
you know,
and that they wouldn't do that.
But you're saying they would all do it?
No,
not all.
There is definitely a core group of
champions who have never thought about
taking drugs and still don't have a
problem with steroids.
There's a lot to do.
Promo.
Sarah is also.
Is that when one person starts doing it,
the person beneath him either will lose
or has to be pressured to do it and so
it creates this like,
and sorry if people out there are upset
that I'm not a sports fan,
I'm don't think about them.
Let's just talk.
Do you believe that's what's holding us
back?
Don't sweat it.
You do though?
I don't.
I mean I'm just like,
sports are holding us back.
Is that what you mean?
Thinks he's doing a what's elevating us?
That's holding us back.
What's the elevator making sports like?
Our main thing I hate when sports are on
in any sort of public establishment.
I think it's aesthetically okay.
I want to tell yourself it's okay.
You don't like when you see sports in an
establishment.
I find it depressing,
depressing,
but what about law and order when you
watched that?
That's like one notch down,
but very depressing.
CSI.
Pull the head off the carpet to the
head.
For our Natasha I will say is a.
is extremely connected to aesthetics
more than any human being I've ever met.
I think tennis is a nice aesthetic.
There you go.
Okay.
I would.
I was told that's a sport.
I know.
It's okay.
I think like a tennis match.
Yeah,
I could handle that.
Why is that okay.
And like honestly because I like how
they like how they dress.
What about basketball?
No,
no,
I hate those long stories.
No,
I don't like baseball or
darkness to play tennis.
Yeah,
just a couple of chicks are really good
at it.
I mean I think
it's probably because I grew up and I
was always the last to get picked for
sports,
so maybe that's why it was so totally
want to go deep
when I hug you.
I'm always worried I'm going to break
you.
You,
you weighed like 80 pounds.
I wish you a hundred and five.
Come on.
You do not weigh 100 pounds.
You Line Yourself.
Do you do.
I mean,
I'm not like that skinny.
I'm just
small.
She weighs 105 while we fuck and it's
101.
We're not fucking I a five pound debt.
I mean I didn't.
I didn't want to mention that.
I asked the test and I had to bring it
up,
but it needs to be said.
Yeah.
I've got an Alonzo Bowden to have lots
of document for Alonzo and fingers.
You about the sport?
No,
you don't have to.
Excuse me.
I don't like sports.
I also don't like video games.
The only thing I watch is fighting.
I literally don't watch sport.
I don't.
I don't even know the rules.
Like you don't like any sport other than
MMA and boxing.
I don't watch them.
I don't.
I don't even know when they're
happening.
Like when someone says,
oh,
just see the NBA championship game.
Like Oh,
when was it?
No,
it was last night,
man.
You didn't watch.
I'm the same as the thing.
The only sport I watched his MMA and
have watched consistently since I was a
kid,
his mma and then boxing very secondarily
and that I can't get into kickboxing at
all.
Really?
Laurie?
I've seen clips of everything.
I don't know why I can't.
I can't get into because I like him and
made much more than boxing.
But then you would think I would be more
in the kickboxing and boxing,
but I'm not.
Sports just seems like men exercising.
That's funny.
But like I just,
I mean I know it's more than that,
but like if you saw opera,
you'd probably be like,
this just seems like fat people
screaming or screened opera.
Do you like it?
No,
I felt like it was just like antiquated
form of entertainment that I watch.
I was super duper high when I went to
see you because I knew,
I knew I had to see.
It was like,
oh,
just I had to do a favor.
So,
uh,
when I,
when I went to watch,
I was like,
listen,
I'm just kidding.
Bullies out of my fucking mind.
But what's interesting is I,
what I really started paying attention
to was all the people in the audience
and there's like this class of people
that probably live in Bel Air and
Beverly Hills and want to be seen at the
opera and it's like a big deal to say
they're going to the opera and I was
watching this,
it was like they can't possibly like
this,
like even if they like it,
they don't like it,
that they don't like it.
Like people like the UFC.
That's true.
You're right.
100 percent.
What he's saying is pretending to like
there's a different level to what the
light.
It's not true.
It's like sophisticated entertainment.
I mean like we went to the,
to the orchestra,
the symphony recently.
And I hated it.
I've been,
I went to the symphony when I was a kid
with my grandma.
She used to take me and there are some
bangers,
you know?
Yeah.
You know like Dun Dun,
a Banger,
the,
you know,
that he was just in there like doing
this thing.
But we went to see,
I don't even.
Who Was it?
Mahler and you read the description,
Mahler and it's like laminations on
death,
not a discord and not pleasant to listen
to.
So we're going to go sit down for an
hour and a half.
Performance of like something that in
its description is like Natasha.
You didn't like it either,
did you?
No,
and there was like a low.
Moshe got in a fight with two different
elderly people.
He tried to help this woman.
I was walking in like double crutches.
It's so old you can't
imagine.
It's like it's so old and so white.
It's like unbelievable.
You can't believe it,
you know?
And I was walking in and this old man
was a sitting down and he's like 85,
and so I told him he started to get up
to let me throw it go,
you don't need to get up.
I can kind of crawl around you.
And he goes,
we're not all as young as you.
Some of us are gonna die soon.
And I was like,
Oh,
I'm trying to go.
I just read the wikipedia page.
I go like,
oh,
well I guess that's what we're here to
listen to.
Right,
and the guys,
nothing iced me out and I sit there like
bored and the worst and it's got.
It's the worst kind of symphony Mahler
because it always seems like it's ending
it be like,
Duh,
Dun Dun Dun,
and you're like,
cool,
let's get the fuck out of it.
Done.
Never got the old lady who yelled at you
and she almost fell down the stairs.
Then as
we were leaving,
I was an old man and he was so feeble
and and wobbly that I was staring at his
body like in my mind,
you ever have this kind of situation
where you're like this,
this is going to,
this person's going to fall.
I can feel it in my bones were way
before it happened
in the steepest possible.
It would and I could feel it like if
this guy's gonna fall,
he's too feeble.
He's too old to be ascending the stairs
and he sure enough does.
He just starts to tip over and he goes
for it because I was already like
looking at him.
I grabbed him by like the,
the,
the top,
the collar and the bottom of his jacket
and I just held him up,
right?
Oh my God.
And he fucking like,
just like shoved me off of him,
gave me a dirty look and stormed off.
And I was like,
I just saved your fucking life.
You all bitch wanted to go.
Maybe you want way to go.
Listen to them all.
I listened to Mahler out depressing
shit,
pretends he slips.
Listen to his wife complaining about her
stool.
I saw blood in my stool and he's like,
I'm just going to fall.
You know my grandma Gloria.
So to good,
steep angle,
my grandma said to me what he said to me
on her deathbed,
like days before she died,
she looked at me and she said,
if there is a god,
he saves a worst part of your life for
the very end.
It's like,
bye bye grandma.
Thinking about that,
because I was like going into a like an
old person's home seems so depressing.
Like I would never want to do that to go
away from your,
your stuff in your house.
You know,
like,
I'm just trying to think what's the best
way to go.
I think it will be
themselves in a home will alone when
they're super depressing too,
right?
Yeah.
I lived in New York when I first moved
there.
I stayed with my grandparents in New
Jersey and my grandmother had had an
aneurysm.
They gave her 72 hours to live.
She lived 12 years.
Wow.
Yeah,
Dude.
Yeah.
It was over those 12 years.
I was only there living with them for a
few months.
I think I lived there for maybe five
months,
six months,
but it was bad.
It was bad.
Like my grandfather,
they had a nun or a non.
A nurse would come over and they would
help,
but this like she would have horrible
bedsores.
She couldn't move.
She was paralyzed.
She was completely vegetables.
She would talk a little bit on your
teeth were falling out.
They had all fallen out.
She want to live at that point.
No,
no,
but I do think like the two ways,
the two main ways to die or like to have
a death bed,
like that seems kind of glamorous
because then you could like call people
to you and give them wisdom and like
have last words.
No,
but if,
if you die in an accident,
then you never get to have any of that.
No.
You can't have those funny last year
or the third way.
What is the,
what is you,
you're a bit about your grandma and her
deathbed.
I don't remember the third.
The third way though is to go mad and to
shit your pants.
And two,
my grandmother didn't die like that
though.
That's just the job.
My grandma did.
My grandma's great fear.
Her entire life was becoming a feeble
senile person that was to herself and of
course it came true because the only way
to avoid that is to have a heart attack
or an accident.
I feel bad that I say that about my
Nana.
It was just a dumb joke.
Well,
you know,
they have assisted death now in
California and 11 people did it on the
day.
That's crazy.
Please.
My absolutely did in the first day,
which I absolutely believe in.
I mean I think God damn it.
Why do we need to have people die of
natural causes when they're horribly
suffering?
And
that's a good question,
right?
It's like what is suffering?
If you are physically fine,
you have a 70 beats per minute resting
heart rate.
You have no cancer but you just five
pounds everyday,
five pounds deck every day.
Hating life.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
In Scandinavia where they've had
euthanasia for a long time,
they started to accept that the person
who suffering from chronic depression
can opt out and take assisted suicide as
a means to escape their depression.
Isn't a part of the problem with pro,
with chronic depression,
like we don't know what they're feeling.
Like if you.
If like someone,
if you have a broken arm,
like,
okay,
I broke my arm,
I kinda get it,
but if someone says I have chronic
depression,
I was like,
okay,
what does it feel like?
I don't know.
I don't know what your depression is and
in your chronic depression might be
different than another person and
another person.
It's like,
how do you know that it can't be turned
around with a pill or with exercise and
diet,
and if you did turn it around like I
have friends that were suicidal and now
they're super happy.
So it's hard.
Well,
the problem is the main one of the main
tenants of depression is hopelessness.
So if you can't feel at all hopeful,
how are you ever going to try to get
your way out?
Another strange thing about mental
illness in my experience,
and I have a lot of it in my family,
uh,
and is that it always looks,
not always but it off,
except for schizophrenia and stuff.
Looks obviously like that person's sick
and can't help it.
But with depression or alcoholism,
that kind of thing.
It always feels like you could act
differently if you just tried a little
bit harder.
You could not be doing this.
You could be less depressed.
You could go apply for a job,
you could get up a look at the front.
He has schizophrenia.
You can see as impossible,
but it looks to the normal brain like
close enough to normal that they could
just change your circumstance if only
they tried harder and mental illness is
maybe the inability to try harder,
so it's very seductive to the normal
brain to think of mentally ill people is
like lazy or not trying to get better.
Yeah.
I just think it's one of those very odd
things to quantify of almost impossible.
Like I don't know what you're feeling,
you know,
and what is like what's normal for some
people,
you know,
and like some people are just ecstatic
all the time and like what,
what is normal for them.
And also the antidepressants are like
literally just a chemical experiment
with somebody's brain,
go tinkle this and do this.
Yeah.
I know people who ever since they
started taking antidepressants,
it's changed their life and their
lifestyle better.
Sure.
Have you ever taken either of you ever
taken an antidepressant?
No.
Someone gave me some adderall once.
That's not similar bid on entity.
I was on it when I was a kid when I was
a 13,
12 year old media personality.
Changing,
I remember my brain doing things to me
that I didn't like physically.
Like I started to see things in the
horizon of my vision.
I started diff.
My,
I started to feel like less hungry.
I started to like see things in the
horizon of your vision,
you know,
like actual apparitions,
not apparitions,
like,
uh,
like sort of like sort of hallucinogenic
fractal situations,
you know,
I started to see that and it just like I
could feel it tinkering with my brain.
I of course,
what was happening was I was getting
given antidepressants to combat,
like being a juvenile delinquent,
like Druggie,
and so it wasn't treated.
It wasn't treating thing that existed.
So a psychiatrist gave you this?
Yeah,
I was all fucked up with psychiatrists
that is will give you,
that's the real problem,
right?
They'll give it to people that don't
need it.
That's what's happening with the opiod
crisis.
Like they'll,
people just like,
they'll just give you oxycontin.
Like it just seems so crazy.
It was crazy.
This doctor told me this weekend,
I was talking to a family member that's
a doctor that it takes eight days of,
of a regimen of,
of what's the drug in the,
in the car.
There's one drug that the,
all the opiate addicts are getting
addicted to Oxycontin.
It's not oxycontin,
fentanyl,
fentanyl.
It takes me for dead eight days to get
hooked and a and a treatment regiment is
something like 12 days.
So it's like everybody that's given the
treatment regimen for regular pain is,
is having to kick it when they get off.
And that's why.
That's why we've got a crisis that is
incredible.
That eight days in you're hooked.
It's insane
because everybody who takes,
if you break your leg or something,
they give you fentanyl.
No.
Um,
I don't know why they give it to you.
Medical marijuana for a broken leg for
pain is real simple.
I mean,
you're saying it like you haven't
thought it through like that because
they make a lot more money selling you
something you can't get anywhere else.
Too naive.
It's not like the first rule of being a
doctor.
We're not going to hurt
relationships with pharmaceutical
companies.
I mean,
so it's a standard appointment believe
that people are like that,
but there's also a bunch of doctors that
are ignorant to the actual positive
benefits of pot.
They have a negative association about
pot.
People don't smoke pot,
but also to get real.
Like if you have a compound fracture,
you don't.
What you need is more than medical
marijuana at least at first.
You don't agree with me.
Oh,
you would take your phone.
Is your bones sticking out of your leg
and your parts.
You pop it back in and what you.
What would you take?
Only once you get the cast on it,
you're fine.
It just,
she just sit there.
It sucks when you move,
but you don't have to take that stuff.
You don't have medical marijuana.
Supposedly they did a recent test and 93
percent of people with chronic pain
preferred marijuana over opiates.
God,
I can.
My mom has pain and like she's never
tried drugs and I just can't get her to
try.
You know,
like there's such a stigma,
like she'd probably try phentenol before
because a doctor,
a doctor said it was okay.
Then marijuana.
I wish we could change the.
We are not a fan of pain pills.
I hear you reconstructed and I didn't
take anything.
I just.
I'm like,
I'm not taking them.
We took marijuana though.
Or Smoking Pot luck.
How much did you suffer?
It's not that
bad.
It's just paint.
Depends on your.
Yeah.
That's the kind of pain that you just
go,
okay,
well that's what that feels like.
Okay,
now I know what that is.
Back pain is one of the harder ones.
Like everything you do,
that's a very overrated pain by the way.
It's nothing.
It's like scratches.
It feels like.
I know I've heard people say it hurt
more than anything in their life,
so your people are pussies,
doesn't it?
Doesn't hurt them.
It just doesn't hurt that much.
It really just does.
It just absolutely does not hurt that
much.
There's spots where it's not comfortable
like bones,
like elbow bone when they go over the
elbow bone and oddly enough,
like right when they get close to your
chest,
that's painful,
but not childbirth.
There's fucking manageable.
You just go,
whoa.
It was like just.
I think a lot of it is just how you
think about the course and the fester.
What's the most painful?
Does anyone know what the most painful
thing of human being can experiences?
What's like?
The top threshold seems to be a compound
fracture is as bad as it gets,
but maybe I'm told I just seems awful.
Broken.
Broken bones suck and broken.
A compound fractures is a broken bone
and in a horrible laceration.
Oh,
right.
I guess that's true.
I have a broken arm and it wasn't that
bad,
but burning.
I think you're right.
Burning burning is one of the most
absolutely painful ones.
Burning,
not burning to death.
I think that that's rough,
that recovery process from.
Do you know that when burn victims are
in the hospital,
other burn victims,
random strangers go to them and talk to
them.
Wow.
I didn't know that.
My friend Zack is that craiger who's
from the widest kid,
you know,
and he's a successful actor.
He's on that show,
wrecked.
Uh,
he told me he burned himself at a party
in the Caribbean and in the Caribbean
people would go visit,
burn victims from the Caribbean would go
visit him
because apparently the pain is so
intense and insane that they
interesting.
Let me say this now before I forget.
Um,
people who love Steve.
Oh,
Steve.
did something.
I don't know what the fuck he did,
but on his instagram,
if you're going to denver this weekend,
Steve,
I was going to be in Denver.
He has horrible burns all over his body
and he's looking for some sort of an emt
to take care of him,
like someone to help him dress his
wounds because he's still going to do
his shows at the comedy works and
apparently it's going to.
You won't tell the story of what
happened to him,
but he put it because he wants to tell
it onstage,
but he put these images will put a video
of it up on instagram and his fucking
skin is falling off of his arm.
Really bad.
Yeah,
it looks really bad.
Don't do your show,
Dude.
Want to say to Steve,
have you listen to this?
There's a new stem cell therapy that
they've created for people that have
burns where they spray stem cells all
over the burn and the healing time is
radically reduced as well as the
scarring.
The scarring is radically reduced.
So another thing we tend to look into
that
they put tilapia skin on the burner you
heard about this low fish scales on
apparently is one of the much so much
more healing than bandages.
I don't know why,
but it like creates this sort of,
you know,
skin on skin healing and it did
apparently the doctors trying
prostitutes burn victims using fish
skin.
That's fascinating.
I'm going to be okay.
He's going to be okay.
But he's gotta go to the Steevo
instagram page so you could see it.
But this stem cell treatment is pretty
radical.
Like they've shown people with third
degree burns.
They sprayed on them and in a couple of
days it's gone.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Like literally no scar.
No nothing.
It just heals.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
we're,
we're in a new world.
Uh,
not this.
And the next one.
The next one.
Did you take it off?
What about that one?
Oh,
that man,
he took it down.
That's a video of him getting blood
poured on his face.
Took it down.
Whoa.
That's crazy.
He was asking for people to come and see
him in Denver,
like all that stuff all over his body.
All those.
Like he showed what that looked like.
Click on that because it just seems
like.
Yeah,
fuck.
This is one video that he had.
This is not going to show anything,
but the next video he showed what's
going on under those bands
and it's horrific.
Oh,
maybe it got flagged.
What's,
what's the most painful thing you've
ever experienced?
I don't know.
Um,
I feel like I'm so lucky.
What about you?
You got nothing.
Your shoulder?
I'm a baby.
Her shoulder popped out in Hawaii and it
was painful though.
It was.
I just don't like getting blood drawn.
I felt very weak as a man at that
moment.
She popped out of the ocean and her
shoulder was like separated body surfing
and I was just like,
you did you get an Mri?
Do you know what's going on?
Oh yeah.
It was like three years ago.
It was a dislocated.
Yeah,
right.
But no tearing or anything like that.
I apparently,
it doesn't feel the same.
Dislocated my shoulder.
I didn't even know weird because I could
see it physically on her body.
She doesn't have as much muscle as you,
but I was looking at her arm going like,
I don't know what to do about that.
I don't know what I'm going to do.
I guess I could hoist her on my shoulder
and walk back because it was like there
was a wall.
It just popped back
posted.
Like for some people you're supposed to
like lay them down and stretch their arm
or pull it out and then it'll fall back.
In.
The most I know about shoulder
dislocations is from lethal weapon,
so slam them up against the wall.
Do they throw it into yourself?
Just have loose shoulders.
Like I know some girls who like every
time she has sex or like one out of five
times her shoulder becomes dislocate.
I'll be honest,
Joe touched on some of the loosest
shoulders in the game.
Maybe those girls are just like drama
queens.
No,
no.
Always going like this and they just
like being hurt.
Whether fucking.
Can you imagine though how bad that
would be if you were fucking the girl
and her shoulder got dislocated?
Yeah.
That was really bad or good or some
pads.
Solar pads.
Some shoulders,
some football town support.
Yeah.
I do that anyway just because I like a
more masculine woman,
so I liked her to be wearing big back
something with a
just like give her a little Tbi.
Traumatic booty injury,
jail.
It's so easy to go to jail now.
Yeah.
We should be in jail just for saying
this right
now so we can.
Aren't you glad to not be dating right
now?
Oh yeah.
It seems like a nightmare for everybody
to know.
That is.
It seems so scary.
If you get lucky and find someone that's
awesome.
It's great.
It's a good time and it's fun and
exciting.
But most of the time,
well,
you know,
I remember,
you know like now it's like if,
if,
if a girl wants to,
she can just say that she didn't consent
and you'd probably make them fun forms,
fill out forms,
but you didn't need forums.
I think she'd have a stack of them next
to the bed just to let chicks.
No,
that's.
This is like really casual.
Like they do that though.
All these so many forms.
All these big stars do that.
They make you like instagram cruise.
Not like the beat,
there was a story about Justin Bieber
will make you like videotape yourself
saying like,
I'm of sound mind and body and I choose
to fuck Justin Bieber,
you know,
oh,
that makes sense,
or whatever,
because he's fucking little skanks
allegedly and uh,
you know,
they're probably trying to get over on
them.
And I would imagine if you're that
wealthy,
like you have to worry about everything
you do all the time.
I'm sure there are a lot of guys who are
probably trying to take advantage of
girls,
so for sure.
Maybe there's more of that.
Maybe that's on the rise.
So it's bad for you.
Boy.
I bet it's the same as it's always been.
There's always been creeps in.
There's always been creeps on both
sides.
This is the thing is that there,
there's more creeps in the men's side.
Let's get real.
I mean there's more like there's more
psychos,
maybe more crazy people that you date,
but there's more predators that you as
there are more male predators than there
are female.
I'm sure there are female partners and
their cycle men,
but if we were to really do some number
crunching,
you know,
I would imagine it's not even.
I've never had,
it's 50 slash 50.
I've never had an experience that I was
actively scared and I've had experience
where I was like,
I'm not spending the night at this
girl's house because I don't know if I'd
wake up
our friend.
This girl emailed him and we left.
Well,
I'm just saying there's two real.
I remember this one girl,
I was at her house
and I was like,
oh,
I,
this person maybe would kill me in my
sleep.
She was,
uh,
she was crazy.
She was,
I remember she kept,
she was like real Hollywood,
like punk trash right when I moved to
town.
You okay with this story?
And uh,
she,
she
kept going.
She kept asking me to put a cigarette
out on her and I was like,
I don't think I can do that and I don't
think I can do that,
but I would like an ash on her.
We're like full put.
And then I remembered that she was,
um,
she was,
she kept when she was,
she would go down on me and she kept
like horribly but biting me and my
genitals and she was like biting my
balls,
I remember and I was like,
please stop that.
Like please,
please know.
And then all of a sudden we kept
making out and she looked down and she
looked.
She was like,
what is that like a,
the way you say,
uh,
what is that when somebody is got like
an std,
right?
You know,
that like,
what,
what is this?
And I looked down and there was a
fucking contusion in my nuts,
like a hiding it from her bite.
She like burst a blood vessel and
there's like a mad about it.
She wouldn't know she had and
she had done it and not,
you'll have a little respect for my
wife's in the room.
So she's sucking my balls.
So Hi
friend emailed him,
said,
just so you know,
I know he didn't have sex,
but if we had permission and it would
have been
right,
right.
She goes,
what does our friend who was her friend
was at at Reed College actually were or
not.
Were you?
Yeah,
so read a read.
Not Evergreen,
but read where it's like the center of
like the woke sort of PCC campus culture
and she extreme.
That's very extreme.
She called him and said she was drunk
and she came onto him and was like,
his name is Andrew [inaudible].
He's a,
he's A.
Oh,
I shouldn't say that.
maybe I shouldn't say that because I
just blatantly telling him he didn't do
anything.
No,
no.
He d,
She came onto him.
Let's not say her name now.
I don't know who she is,
but he's a comedian and I just figured
he'd want a shout out,
but at any rate,
he's a great comedian.
He,
he definitely avoided the punchline.
So
at any rate,
he,
he didn't hook up with her.
She came onto him and he was like,
okay,
I'm not feeling this.
No,
thank you.
Went home,
went to bed,
a gay guy.
And uh,
and then she,
she texted him like a week later was
like,
I just wanted to thank you for not
taking me home that night because I was
drunk.
It wouldn't have been consensual.
It would've been raped.
So thank you.
It's just like,
well,
that's how a lot of people want to
firmly established that though,
that if you're an adult and you're
drinking and you have sex,
it's rape.
Well,
it is hard though because you have to
understand being a woman,
you are so vulnerable.
Like men have more upper body strength.
We do have a whole.
And they have a thing that goes into the
whole.
Whoa,
you're saying crazy things right now
that no one knows.
No,
but it's like we drop that kind of
knowledge.
You have to
yourself.
Imagine yourself if you had a whole
instead and you didn't have those
muscles and you were just walking
around,
you know,
well,
what is the idea that women or men are
afraid that women are going to laugh at
them?
Women are afraid men are going to kill
them.
Yeah.
Those are both very different things.
But that's the reality is that just like
when you say there's like the equal
dispensation of predators on the side,
it's like,
well no,
there really aren't.
Right.
That really is.
I said there's creeps in both sides.
Don't necessarily think it was equal.
What I mean is,
and I'm not trying to.
I wasn't doing that to like I said that,
but I did probably was flippant.
But my point is that,
that the world that women walk around in
is one where they fear that the worst
case scenario is they're going to be
kidnapped,
raped,
and murdered.
In our worst case scenario is usually is
not that.
Yeah.
Well exactly the rate part in
particular.
Most of the time it's not that.
And if it is,
it's also from a fucking
man from a dude.
Yeah.
I mean I,
I had an argument with a guy who's a
men's rights activist about that.
He was like,
actually more men are raped and women
are stupid.
They're raped by men.
Fuck.
You're just reinforcing the argument
against men.
That's like such a dumb argument.
Well,
they always like,
they haven't even looked into it.
They like,
they like,
it's such a surface thing to say like,
have you done like the next step?
Like who's raping?
Oh yeah,
guys probably shouldn't bring it up.
Yeah,
you should probably shouldn't bring it
up.
Do you want her to support men?
If you like.
Your whole thing is that men are
awesome.
Like men are actually.
The victims were raped more than women.
Right.
By what?
Goblins.
Let's fucking.
Demons are coming
middle of the night and raping you.
That's a good point by other men.
But this guy was saying it like,
I got you with this fact that I bet you
did know
well,
because people like to talk and talking
points.
They don't like to.
I mean
a lot of experience with the alt right
people on your show.
What's that?
Just that they don't think things
through.
Like remember that guy was trying to
tell you that the people at the woman's
march,
he's like,
how did they take off their,
their work and it's like it was on a
Saturday,
right?
Did we have this guy on the show?
That was like,
the problem is it was all out of work.
People that just,
I don't know about.
This was a talking point in the right
about the women's marches or just about
protests in general.
I don't know how these people are able
to have such privileged that they can
just take work off to go protest.
It's like,
first of all,
there's a history of protest where
people strike.
That's the whole idea.
But second of all,
the women's march in particular was on a
Saturday,
so it was this guy who is this guy named
kid named Lucian wind trich.
Now you were asking who is?
Yeah.
Good.
All right.
Brian,
this reason I came to you because we
were trying to get a.
basically we did the show right?
And we started with cultural
appropriation.
We ended with the outright with meet the
outright.
Right.
And so we were trying really hard to
really explore ideas.
Right.
And I guess if there's,
if there's one thing I realized in the,
in the wake of,
uh,
we definitely triggered the outright
with that cultural appropriation thing.
People were very upset that we even
broached the topic without condemning it
essentially,
and I think there's.
There's one thing I realized in the wake
of all of the show is like,
there's one position I truly don't
respect.
It's,
I disagree with you,
therefore I won't listen to you.
Fuck you.
That's,
that's really.
There's nothing about that that I have
any respect for.
No,
I completely agree.
I think I want to know how you came to
that conclusion and oftentimes you could
find if you.
I mean especially if you particularly
disagree with something someone says and
you thought your side through and you
talk to someone with an open mind,
you can actually find like the holes in
their logic and it'll help you
understand.
Maybe you got some holes in your own
logic,
not aware of them.
Exactly.
Experiences they're drawing from to help
come up with their way of thinking.
Right?
Yeah,
and I definitely exploring all those
topics found just what you're saying.
I found like the part of the gun
argument that I really fully wrapped my
brain and my heart around the,
the pro gun second amendment right.
I mean,
I'm still not like a wildly pro gun guy,
but I totally 100 percent this
understanding of where they were coming
from that I never had before.
That really,
you know,
a lot of the condemnation of the left is
that they condemn identity politics.
Right?
And really when it comes to second
amendment,
stuff it.
And also the truth is the outright to.
It's also identity politics is just
identity politics and the reverse.
It's not like left this identity
politics,
it's more gun owner identity.
Like in other words,
when you condemn a gun owner,
you're,
you,
the liberal thinker is going,
oh,
I'm condemning guns,
I'm condemning violence.
And what you don't understand is you're
condemning a person with their hearing
is you're calling them their identity.
They're the thing that makes them
passionate,
a illegitimate stupid,
and based in ignorance and violence.
And of course a person's going to react
and go,
go fuck yourself.
I'll never listened to your argument.
If you start your argument by basically
telling them their whole lifestyle is
bullshit.
Yeah,
there's a real problem with the gun
ownership argument and one of the big
problems is the mass shootings,
right?
Everybody condemns mass shootings.
They're horrible.
They're terrifying,
and they only happen with most of the
time people with guns.
I mean we've had some situations
recently in Europe where people driving
over people with cars and there's a lot
of insane shit that's going on over
there with that and then people had been
stabbing people in some places,
but for the most part it's guns.
Right?
But my thought on it is always that it's
a mental health issue.
There are more guns in this country than
there are people.
So if you have 300 million guns and
every once a year or so one of these
things happens and you have this mass
shooting this horrible tragedy.
One of the most constant things,
his mental illness,
almost all those people are either on
psycho psychoactive medicine.
Either they're on some sort of anti
psychotic or an antidepressant or the
coming off of it.
They have a history of psychiatric
treatment,
a history of,
of illness,
of mental illness.
It's 100 percent.
It's almost 100 percent of people that
are like severely mentally ill.
We have horrible standards for mental
illness in this country for people just
being roaming around the street and a
lot of that came from Reagan when Reagan
let those people.
Yes.
When they let those people loose,
that means people need fucking
treatment.
They need help.
It's a lot of them.
So a lot of people that are on
dissociatives,
they're on all these anti psychotic
medication.
They're fucked up man.
Like they real issues and then they can
get ahold of guns.
I agree with you,
but I also think there's a flaw in that
logic because the mass shootings didn't
start commensurate with the shutting
down of the mental health facilities in
California.
When did they.
I,
they,
they seem to me to be a more.
I mean,
Kent State obviously was the original.
No,
Kent State was the National Guard.
I'm sorry,
what was the loan in the tower in
Austin,
Texas in 10 states in Ohio.
Excuse me.
Yeah.
That,
that was like the first,
uh,
the first big one.
But the modern phenomenon of the mass
shooting is,
it is a fairly modern one.
It feels like the last 20,
10,
20 years,
right.
You know that that guy in the tower was
mentally ill.
Oh,
I'm not disagreeing with you at all.
That there's.
That mental illness is a huge part of
the pie.
You're saying the Reagan thing.
I'm not saying the Reagan thing is,
is that 100 percent the reason for it,
but it's a big part of why there are so
many mentally ill people that were
released in that time.
I mean,
I can remember when I was a kid because
my dad was talking about it,
he was like,
it's crazy.
There's like so many more homeless
people now.
That's someone and they're talking to
themselves.
They're all fucked up.
We just abandon these human beings
because their brains aren't working.
Right.
The idea,
the idea was that Reagan shut down all
the mental health facilities in
California and the idea was that they
would be replaced by community centers
where each community,
each neighborhood would have like a
check and send out the check and centers
of course were never built,
so the people just hit the streets.
Fornia was.
I thought it was when Reagan was
president.
I go,
it'd be changed the standards.
National,
national.
I could be wrong nationally,
right?
I could be wrong.
It was when he was president.
I might be wrong.
I saw dark man made the check in.
They just didn't exist.
I mean,
what was the only thing I was saying
though was that it's.
There's something else happening in
America that's like almost feels
mystical or spiritual with it when it
comes to mass shootings because it's
like there are other countries with
mentally ill people that have access to
guns.
That and maybe it's that we,
that we have a less,
a lesser standard of care for mentally
ill,
but cal Canada also has people babbling
on the streets.
Although they have limited access to
guns.
There's something else going on,
it feels like to me,
and that this is totally anecdotal and
just my opinion,
but feels like to me there's some thing
that we don't understand that it is of
course mental in this entity that is of
course access to guns and there's some
third thing that people don't really
can't put your finger on,
which is like,
why is this happening here?
Why is it happening so much here?
Well,
it could be related to overpopulation.
He could be related to the sort of
established mindset of the American
people.
Like why are Canadian so much nicer when
they're connected to us?
Like you just like if you look at the
landmass,
there's no real line,
but you go across the culturally.
Yeah,
they're,
they're way nicer.
They're just nicer,
you know,
and they're,
they talk like us,
they look like us,
they pronounce a few words differently
and they're way nicer,
you know,
and they don't get a lot of mass
shootings up there at super uncommon.
It's interesting.
I mean it's based on this.
I think it's about the connection of
America to its guns is based on.
It's,
it's,
it's a foundation mythology.
It's religion in a weird way,
right?
The religion of America,
the greatest country on earth.
Well,
it's based.
It's a lot of.
It's based on fear means it's freedom
for sure,
but a lot of like the tactical people,
like the people that are really,
really into what happens if somebody
breaks in and you've got to be ready to
go up,
pulled that gun out on two point two
seconds,
got to be able to Tink,
tink,
shoot targets.
I mean there's people that I know people
are good friends that practice that shit
all the time and if you break into their
house you are fucked because they're
ready and they're looking for it.
They want people to break.
I know people were asking people police
break into my phone.
I took Natasha to shoot guns in
anticipation of this gun episode that we
did with the it so much I can't say I
love to do.
I will.
I got there and I thought I'd make a
joke because you have to pick your
little target.
So I was like,
are there any trump?
I'm nudging her,
like Natasha,
we are not in the right area.
We got the Hillary's coming in next
week.
Oh,
real hillary.
That you could shoot me.
I think he was just talking shit to her
for asking the trucks.
Yeah,
probably talk with a southern accent.
It was a side of twice
and then we get in there and there's
people just like doing magazine rifles.
And then there's a guy going through
saying,
uh,
what was he saying?
Like,
no rapid fire,
rapid fire because they're just like,
just like these kids.
It was pretty crazy,
like there weren't even dividers in
between us.
Oh.
And then he was telling me how to work
the gun and I was like,
he's like,
make sure that your thumb doesn't go
here.
Okay,
go ahead.
And I was like,
wait,
wait.
Where is my thumb?
Not supposed to go,
can I,
will you please?
Because I know he didn't know motion had
no either way.
Go Laugh and pointed me.
Motherfucker was this little little poof
over here.
Scared too.
We did a one.
I didn't know I did the.
We did what we had got like 50 rounds.
Yeah,
we bought,
we bought two cars.
You have to buy the ammunition in like a
box you can't buy like all have.
So we bought two boxes thinking we'd be
there for awhile.
The training,
the training session was literally 10
seconds.
Thirty seconds on.
Put your hand here,
put that there.
Okay.
Here's your gun.
Go shoot.
And people are rapid firing and you're
surrounded by other people that got that
same safety briefing.
Right?
Right.
And,
and there's a celebrity wall,
one celebrity Shiela booth,
right.
This is not what you want to see.
That's a weird one too,
right?
That's what I'm saying.
I lied about being there.
It was a picture of him there.
So I shot the gun and she shot it and
then I shot it again and I'm feeling
like I gotta get Outta here.
Natasha was like,
I got to get it.
I just think it was a bad.
I think every gun advocate or strong gun
person we've talked to since said about
that particular place,
like that's not a place to start.
It's not a cool place to unsafe and so
we just,
so I think we picked the wrong place.
At any rate though,
I'm thinking about these two boxes of
ammunition.
I'm like,
I can't go to the dude upfront because
he'll think I'm like a little bitch,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I got all this ammo left,
you know what I mean?
So,
and then she's like,
Natasha,
she's like,
don't be an idiot.
Let's get outta here.
So
that's how I walk up to the front and I
swear I sold her out immediately.
I'm just like,
you know,
I'm trying.
I love it here.
You know,
this is my home baby.
I like how you go black with
southern.
If you want to do an idiot,
you go black.
The guy.
I'm like,
I'm like the wife,
you know what I mean?
The wife is like,
let's get outta here.
You know,
women,
I want to stay,
but I can't.
I got to admit I'm not clicking on say
the wife,
the wife is,
you know,
I'm all like emotional from having shot
a gun.
Like I gotta get Outta here,
but really I'm just like,
you know,
as you well know you want to shoot all
night,
but the live now I'm going Italian.
First time I ever shot one.
The first thing I felt when I went into
the,
the area where put the ear plugs
on and you stand next to these people
and there was these little dividers,
the place that I went.
But when you hear that you feel so
vulnerable.
Yeah.
You feel like,
whoa.
Like if that hits you,
that's a wrap.
They not going to make it.
Yeah,
exactly.
I got to ask you guys this before you
take off.
Just see this trump thing,
the CNN thing,
they're going after the kid who made the
meme heard it wasn't a kid.
Well this is the thing.
Jamille explained the whole thing,
but it was a kid that they went after
who had made a video or made a meme,
but apparently the meme came from a
video and the video was made by someone
else other than this kid and they
essentially.
They threatened to docs this kid,
they.
They said they reserve the right to
expose him and I already 15.
I don't know if that's been 100 percent
proven.
I don't know if it's been 100 percent
disproven,
but I just heard that that is a lie.
It's a lie.
The 15 year old
ness of this kid,
well I don't know if that's the case
because he's not actually 15.
It's because now they're talking about a
different person who created the
original video that was turned into you.
Video,
Gif file,
trump body slamming the.
No,
they're saying that.
That's
so trump.
This is what it is.
Trump was on the wwe and he did a thing
where he slammed to the ground and so
they're gonna.
They took that and put a truck,
a CNN head over the person's body who
trumps slammed to the ground and then
trump tweeted it
offensive.
Very inappropriate.
Very non-presidential.
Pretty fucking funny.
I mean I got
nothing compared to him talking about
that woman having plastic surgery and
saying that her face was bleeding badly
from the face lift.
That's just gross.
Like that is something wrong with him.
That's so beneath anybody.
That's not,
that's not just beneath the president
that's beneath
it is something deeply wrong with him.
He's getting worse.
He's going off these,
these on tissue right now.
Pressure probably getting mentally ill
at this point because the seventies
isn't.
Isn't mental illness like your brain
chemistry changing and can you imagine
what would.
By the way,
when the outright came after me for for
the show,
I had this other realization which is
even people you don't respect if enough
people hate you,
it.
It's,
it's gotta affect on your brain and
imagine being Donald Trump where half of
the world or more is like,
fuck you all day every day.
Half the world.
Imagine a large number of people in the
Republican America.
Exactly,
but it's way more than half of America
now because there's a large number of
people in the Republican Party that are
criticizing.
Right.
It
makes me mad,
is that we called it the women's March
and that no one really gives it respect
for what it was because it was the
largest protest protest in the,
in our history of our lives was to an
anti,
basically an anti trump protest.
Like when that guy was elected and like
we should just be talking about that
more like that's never happened in our
lifetimes or our parents' lifetimes did
it.
There was that big of a.
because someone was being elected and it
just kinda gets pushed to the side.
I mean,
I'm glad it's called the women's march,
but it's just like
basically that we.
The idea of it was marginalized in the
scope of those marginalized because they
called themselves a woman
smart maybe.
I don't know because it's such a huge
deal.
Like I mean it was so exciting to be a
part of that and you saw those pictures
and they weren't just in every city in
America.
They were in every city in the world.
That's how opposed we were.
That didn't happen.
When you know anyone who in our life
times,
it's become kind of a reaction to a
president before.
Never wanted to talk about the CNN.
What's crazy is that CNN is becoming a
monster to fight a monster.
Right,
and they're threatening to dox people
that are making funny memes.
I all that was was funny.
I mean nobody really thought that Donald
Trump was actually slamming the person
that is CNN that doesn't even have a
head that has a cnn for head and
feeling.
Some reporter from CNN was going after
the person.
They track the person down on Reddit who
made the means.
Who gives a fuck?
Who made the memes?
That's what's crazy.
Meme itself isn't offensive.
The name itself is funny.
The offensive part,
if anything,
is that the president of the United
States thought it was appropriate to
retweet it.
It's more dumb than it is.
If it did offend me even slightly,
I saw him that he retweeted.
I was like,
Huh,
that's my reaction.
Listen,
you are correct in my opinion that the
CNN in particular and the press in
general is as filled with warts,
not as filled with warts,
but it's filled with warts in the same
way that the funding
found Dick
joke to make joe that was the right joke
to make the right time didn't mean it
and you're there at the top there.
We would have such a laugh over this.
We've got to sand them off before I see
the Mrs Farmer,
but it's not that.
It's this new realm that we're in where
these cable networks are struggling so
hard to get attention and they're
focusing on really crazy shit.
Like CNN had a bunch of people fired for
making up fake stories about Russia and
trump or not substantiating these
stories and making sure they're correct
before they released it and put it live
and so three people had to resign.
I think it was three CNNS not
struggling.
That's what they're struggling.
They're down 20 percent and rating.
I thought CNN and MSNBC and some other
left leaning thing,
although I don't really consider CNN
left leaning is like at the top of the
charts now
what I read,
and it might be bullshit,
I don't know.
Well,
let's pull this up.
See if you could find out.
What I read was that CNN is down 20
percent since June,
and that Fox is actually up 20 percent.
No,
no.
So lots of splits like typed and CNN
ratings.
It says chump is way off on cns ratings
being down and trump said,
no,
I didn't.
I didn't hear it from trump.
I heard it from someone else was
probably parroting trump.
I mean,
we're all that there in lies the
problem.
We're all being wrapped filled with
misinformation from both sides.
Each side is so
in their,
in their echo chamber,
but they all accept the left and the
right included all except the
information that they're getting as
Gospel truth that cannot be assailed by
the other side's facts.
And so nobody even knows what the truth
is anymore.
Nobody knows what the argument.
Even if they read it,
it's true.
Oh,
so Fox News,
CNN,
MSNBC,
so trump is responsible for everybody
paying attention now driven by surgeons.
For the Rachel maddow show.
Last word with Lawrence O'donnell.
I have no idea who that is.
MSNBC is up a whopping 86 percent in
local view.
Total viewers.
Wow.
In Primetime.
That's amazing.
You Watch.
Do you watch Rachel Maddow?
No,
she.
I think she's great.
I think she's based.
She's just so good.
Incredibly smart.
Tucker Carlson is a well dressed guy
with a great haircut,
good vibe.
So you know where he is though,
but he is.
Is like this odd bridge between
reasonable people in right wing maniacs.
Yep.
He looked good.
He's a bridge between reasonable people.
Sure.
Compared to Hannity.
Sean Hannity.
So much more reasonable than,
than just a dick though.
That's the problem.
He's an.
He's an asshole to the people he
interviews.
His whole thing is that he bombards them
with like kind of snide interviewing,
that relentless,
snide interviewing until they make a
mistake,
deserve it.
Like he brings up several posture is
people just for.
Because he knows that they're going to
say something stupid.
Deacon mark.
Exactly.
Well,
there's this idea called not picking in
Natasha.
I'll take an uber and you can stay.
Well I.
that's totally fine.
I just.
Weird little moment.
Your relationship.
Sorry.
I had the whole day like just by the
hour,
you know,
and I have to be in Hollywood.
It's,
it's for.
I get it.
It's something I'm doing like I'm,
it's a voiceover,
but we could,
we could bring this whole Tom Cruise.
Whoa.
It's not Tom Cruise and scientology
promo film.
I'm sorry.
It's just I have like partners who are
waiting for me and if I don't get their
writeup for wait a minute for
boring explained.
It's an adr session that I'm hosting a
table from my show,
another period and it's in Hollywood at
four,
so I have to go.
I'm sorry.
No worries.
I had a great time.
I had a great time as well.
I think we learned a lot about each
other
for things.
You guys have an awesome tour.
It's going to take off.
Tell everybody.
July 19th,
we will be in New Orleans,
Louisiana.
My Dad always says the uninsured.
Then we're going to Atlanta,
Miami,
Montreal,
Boston,
New York,
Philadelphia,
Chicago,
Milwaukee,
Minneapolis,
yeah.
We'll be in Brooklyn.
Moshe Kasher.com.
The [inaudible] dot com.
We'd love to.
He does a set.
Sometimes we switch the order and then
at the end we both come out and we'd
been giving people love advice,
live relationship counseling.
It's been really fun and we've helped
some marriages I feel like if you
haven't,
but do you
see.
It's a funny thing to say right there.
Maybe
if you.
Did he give them a microphone and they
asked questions to you?
What would they come up on stage?
We basically they have.
Some of them have one time.
We've helped some people in the most
minor ways.
Like somebody like the cat likes to
sleep on the on the bed and we go,
well,
why don't you once a week put a blanket
down,
let the cat slate.
One guy was like,
well,
I think we have problems because I
wasn't touched by my parents at any
point until I was nine years old and we
were like,
not qualified.
Say I would love to stay here and talk
all day,
or at least for another hour listening.
We can do it another solo podcast after
we leave for another 45 minutes will be
fine.
There's plenty of entertainment out
there for these folks.
Oh,
you want me to stay?
Whatever you want,
but I got to call the uber now.
Then we can wrap it up.
I think you should take whatever you
want.
So we'll wrap this up.
Let's wrap this up.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Have you ever had a more awkward ending
to a podcast?
It was perfect.
I love it.
Awkward.
It wasn't awkward at all.
She's angry.
Conversation in the car.
You guys should.
You should do like,
this is going to be a good stream.
You can tell a lot about a man,
how he does an impression of women,
I mean accurate,
mimic,
and then dice always make them like,
no.
He's like,
can I please?
And then other guys always make them
seem like gay.
Like,
Oh,
where's
Tasha?
I'm not making fun of all women.
I'm just making fun of you.
Oh my God.
My impression of women yourself.
I hate sports.
My impression of women goes like this.
Hi,
I'm Alonzo Bowden,
exercise size with three fingers.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
we wrap this up by.
Thank you guys.
Thank you for having a pleasure.
Thank you.